hello i'm john cena hi i'm pete davidson
and we are guest correspondents for
wired
testing and reviewing workout tech i'm
prepared dressed as peacemaker from the
suicide squad so this should be fun and
i'm just here
[Music]
okay let's get to the first gadget
the suspense is killing me
do we recognize this uh no not at all
what is it i would use my uh clinical
knowledge to say that this is a jump
rope that counts your jumps it's all
ball bearings now they've shifted it
these are obviously 20 weight 40s
obviously there's some knurling on the
side maybe to keep your grip
this feels like it is it is made for the
mass market it feels attainable i don't
want to use the word cheap it is
actually a very cheap jump rope it is 16
it is a steel rope protected by pvc
sheathing which i don't know what the
that is it says it's high quality steel
ball bearings to avoid twisting winding
or bending this speed jump rope can bear
a heavy load
sorry one reviewer says this just made
jumping easier so you could focus on
getting in your zone and having a killer
workout love it five stars angela
and then this other guy who i believe
more said not worth it if i was gonna
have this much problems then i could
just count in my head for all that
matter
so sensitive to the touch you can't even
store it two stars says sims 33.
let's test it out
okay yeah
that's a poor sound guy we need some
help really he's not good
okay i got a few in there i jumped eight
times
i burned one calorie
for 55 seconds and i weigh 95 pounds
i'd say we're about 50 50 accurate jump
count i think the body weight may be off
as a guy who jumped ropes regularly i
think you
smashed it john okay thanks man i
appreciate it
okay here's where i stand on the jump
rope if you like seeing your stats and
data it's not that much more expensive
than a regular jump rope so why not
because you're not gonna break the bank
with it pete would you use this no but
it seems like you had a good time with
it and i would trust your opinion so i
think we like the 16 jump rope that is
also used as a dildo cool all right
there it is on a one to five i give this
a 2.5 that is fair bring on the next
gadget
[Music]
okay uh
this is a box is that a roku it's
actually a tiny gem in my pocket
this is gonna test grip so i would
basically do this
and it would give me a readout how much
do you think this one is something like
this i would be i would bet cost 800
it is a hundred and twenty dollars the
active body active five handheld
isometric strength training device and
it helps you build muscle get toned and
stay fit anywhere this portable strength
training and fitness tool paired with
its companion app gives you 100 plus low
impact workouts that effectively target
different muscle groups in just five
minutes hmm 120 exercises in five
minutes you are definitely on some
clinical amphetamines if you're doing
this workout here are the reviews for
the active five just do something just
move this is the answer five stars
terrible workouts hard to get in a
groove i threw the box away so now i'm
stuck with this horrible paperweight one
star amazon customer didn't even leave
his name
i'm interested to see what you do with
it let's play the setup game follow the
line
oh okay
okay cool all right that's fair this is
my flight path this looks like an atari
game i'm figuring out how to cheat
it's very easy to corrupt
hold this position and press active five
firmly and roughly okay i'll try to
maybe do something like this
17 pounds of strength
26 pounds of strength in the other arm
that's right this is the gun to watch at
the show that's the one you masturbate
with this one
that's not a workout
the activ5 gym in your pocket i don't
like that thing why don't you like it i
just don't like it you know i honestly
can't put my finger on it but this thing
sucks yeah uh
i agree with you i don't like it and
only because it's too easy to cheat like
one set of fingers pressing against
another while this hand is passive could
make more tension to give you a better
score it happens in all of fitness we
try to gamify our results but this is
way too easy to do that i will give this
one star
[Music]
hmm the blaze pod oof rough name okay
it's like
small targets i don't know if they plug
into each other but there's like a weird
thing on the bottom my review of this is
oh just lit up
another one and two just lit up i don't
know how i did that tell us what we have
here well john what you're holding right
now is the blaze pod flash reflex and
reaction training led light pods for a
staggering three hundred dollars the kit
includes four led light pods to create
motivating visual cues and tests for
athletes and trainees pods are extremely
durable can absorb hard hits during an
mma training session but are also
sensitive enough for a light tap beware
of some grump reviewers and take it from
a pro buy these and quit messing around
and then the much more believable review
the suction cups don't stick to any wall
in my warehouse
two stars what a weird flex in my
warehouse
this is a plank challenge tap any of the
pods to start there we go go okay there
we go yep
this is actually pretty cool
it's simon says
yep it's kind of like whack-a-mole and
simon says
yeah that's not worth 300 but you can
cheat
so
the
non-techie way to do this exercise take
the really small plates at the gym and
you stack them and when you're in your
plank position you move them over here
and there's really very little way to
cheat i do like how you know how to
cheat with every single device we use
though you gotta find the flaws and the
flaw is you can gamify the system very
quickly
what do you think of these i actually
kind of like it because it looks fun and
it lights up and i'm a very
simple-minded man so for like me that's
very exciting do you like to be under
the bright lights they also make cool uh
photo filters too like if you're taking
selfies and stuff you can just put them
on your face i'll say two stars two
stars for it lighting up testing an
athlete's reaction time that's pretty
cool but i'm going to get faster at
touching dots and if you're a basketball
player hoping to get quicker at playing
basketball how much does basketball cost
11 11 bucks 12 bucks it's not going to
cost me 300 bring on the next gadget
ooh okay
so from the good folks at theragun
it's i believe their new theragun these
are interesting and once again another
vibration strange parallel between
home intimate amusement and physical
fitness gadgetry how's that feel
it feels insane i love how like toned
and jiggly it looks on your arms this is
a theragun mini handheld percussive
massage device the theragun mini
portable treatment packed with power
theragun mini is your pocket-sized
partner
okay giving you quality deep muscle
treatment with unparalleled portability
how much do you think this one's costing
you john 500 bucks a 200 dollar therapy
okay 200 bucks that's not bad and here
are some reviews the small design def
makes it easier to hit harder spots love
it five stars eric and then judy judy913
says it feels like a jackhammer punching
you over and over i hated this product
returned i wish they showed the reviews
of the people that used it for what it's
really for but yeah i'm using this for
my only fans page yeah
tell us about your experience with a
theragun so i have a very bad back
because i have horrible posture because
i don't like myself i got a fair gun
because i saw a commercial of christiano
ronaldo just like he doesn't even say
anything he's just like sexy looking at
the camera and he's like
you know doing this so i thought it
was like supposed to massage your back
and cut out the middle man and john just
told me that that's actually the
opposite of what it does this is a
hammer
and if you have a hurt arm
and your arm is in pain and your body is
in full defensive mode
you're essentially taking a hammer to it
it's not relaxing the tissue at all it's
aggravating it percussion can be really
good by like waking up all those muscles
and getting them ready for activity but
man if you're in pain don't put a hammer
on something that already hurts that's
the takeaway for this
i love the design it's really small
these things are great on healthy tissue
well because you have all that healthy
tissue so it's actually really great for
you but horrible for someone like me
no you if your back hurts and the rest
of you is okay you get a bunch of
healthy tissue oh thanks john i'd give
this 3.75 stars the only reason it's not
higher is because they're not really
doing a better job of informing people
how to use
how much do you think this
high-intensity vibrating foam roller is
john
150 bucks very close 200. it's a little
pricey for a piece of foam it is german
engineered eco-friendly smooth and
grooved like myself three vibrating
settings for a custom experience
tailored to your recovery and warm-up
needs you can increase the range of
motion by up to forty percent versus
eighteen percent increase with regular
foam rolling ridiculously powerful
vibrations when i use it on my upper
back it makes me feel a bit dizzy
i don't know if that's a positive review
and then negative review all caps stop
working within only several weeks of use
one star
foam rollers are good and they work but
there's also bad because like how many
times you've seen people to gym like
this like uh
on their phones like kicking it pretend
they're rolling out their calves and
they're just like this
the cool thing about the hyper rice
you can't really relax and pete i want
you to know
this could be a great finish to your
workout yeah just gotta get on that
inside edge okay and in about
90 more seconds
my workout will be finished
[Music]
this was good
this one was good
what'd you think i thought it was cool
but i thought that they should have
added a bluetooth speaker as well i mean
it might as well be oh why not
right that would have been sick i like
this thing i actually i actually do own
one something that's helped my bad back
a little bit maybe you should try a run
on the hyper ice this is more for like
the cool down stuff and the relaxing
everything if you have something that's
quite tense the difference is this uses
vibration
it's a little bit less threatening than
percussion but guys add a speaker to it
and for the fact that you didn't add a
speaker to it we're gonna give it
three
three we're gonna give it three stars
that's final
wired it's time for my overall thoughts
is an archaic dinosaur like me who
really doesn't know how to turn on or
off their phone really a justifiable
authority to evaluate this equipment
no
watch rocky iv there's a guy who lifts
logs and runs up mountains and there's
another guy who trains with the highest
technical equipment available it's all
about what you like if you like tech and
you like working out the techie workout
gadgets are for you but you don't need
tech to work out you should definitely
not take my opinion on working out
because i cannot
work out even though i look like i do so
to sum it up we both had a great time
with
my god have you wasted your time trying
to get information from us
[Music]